what's something that you believe in the
crypto space that you think a wide
majority of people would disagree with
you on oh the bitcoins gonna take over
us money that's the I really do believe
it's gonna take money okay explain to us
technology how you get there well I
think it's gonna take 20 years I may be
wrong because again what ice did that's
one of the benefits of what I said was
embraced natively digital assets and so
I think that change over from how we do
it now we're where we have this crazy
system where every financial asset with
very few exceptions is an IOU from a
leveraged financial institution that
might go bust most people don't realize
that yes the stocks in Europe brokerage
account are not stocks they're an IOU
from your broker so the bank account
deposits that you have it's not your
money it's an IOU from a bank and they
may not pay it back to you so I do think
that that you know I thought that it
would take a while to tear down that
infrastructure and I do think it will
take a while but the the the that's why
I said ice broke the seal that's that's
one of the things I complimented them on
they they left over the blockchain not
Bitcoin detour if you will but I thought
was going to take the industry 10 or 20
years and just went straight to natively
digital assets so I you know we may be
surprised at how how fast this takes off
the technology needs to come up to speed
pretty clearly I'm excited about
lightning Network I now that I
understand what that is in not certainly
at a technologists depth but more sort
of from a from a philosopher and
business depth of understanding that you
know that really could make a big
difference yeah do you think that the
accelerate do you think that the
adoption of Bitcoin as money is being
accelerated by some of the
hyperinflation we're seeing around the
world oh no question yeah no question
we're on the day we're recording this is
you know Turkey is we're having an
emerging market correction shall we say
in in a number of emerging markets and
and yeah the the bitcoins already having
a big impact in places like Venezuela
and historically
it has been a safe-haven asset The Wall
Street flows did make it more positively
correlated to traditional financial
assets it was say in the Cyprus
situation very non correlated it was a
safe haven flow and and one of the
things that I've literally just written
in in the book chapter draft is that but
bitcoin will return to its roots as a
safe haven asset it is